let me tell you something I think I told
you this or maybe not I didn't watch the
show when it first came out I didn't
watch the
show till about I want to say five years
ago and my friends swore by it and I go
Chris remember Chris uhhuh we went to
the mall together yep yep I said Chris
come on man it's like high school it's
like I don't he goes Rosen
dude you gotta watch it trust me you got
you'll like
it I was hooked it is such a good show
if you haven't seen it it is every
performance is
so just it's it's it's a it's a show
that should go down history as one of
the great great shows of television in
history it's in the top 10 it is who
judged that I guess New York Times or I
don't know somebody well good and uh
yeah it was honestly it was the best
thing in the it taught me how to really
act
because you know Peter Berg handpicked
everybody on purpose for the reasoning
that he
wanted people to just be raw and
improv and you know like you would walk
into a room and there were three cameras
no
marks and just be like go
and then sometimes you know he'd whisper
something and then our EP director ended
up uh doing this as well Jeff Reiner but
like you know whisper something in my
ear and then go to plem and whisper
something in his ear and we say whatever
it is and then all of a sudden we have
this whole different Dynamic going and
then we'd go into the lines and it just
created this really cool environment
to to work and it was really hard to
relearn how to you know walk up to a
mark
seriously that what a great gift to go
in and go hey we know the lines and
let's go play a little bit let's go play
and let's improvise if we feel like it
and at what I mean what a great
environment and you're doing it all in
film you're shooting on film yeah we
were shooting on film and you know I met
some of my best friends on that show
Connie Britain's still one of my dearest
friends in the world she's like a sister
who did she play she was not the Le mom
the mom I forgot the names of people I
forget the names of people she's
amazing I loved
her he was great too honestly everybody
was great like there isn't a bad I can't
think of one performance where I'm like
H and I'm sure there was some but like
most of these performances were just
Dynamite what like did
you when you look back and you're acting
with Jesse
plens Yeah my buddy can
you remember
thinking he's going to be a big star
this this guy is really great or just
thinking like he's good he's good
honestly no I really
thought to me he always felt like if um
Philip Seymour Hoffman and Matt Damon
had a baby yes that's what he would look
like and you know with that kind of
energy and I knew even when he was I
mean he was one of the youngest but he
was still like my buddy you know what I
mean he was a good hang and he was like
17 or something when we started that
show
and yeah I looked at him I was just like
he's going to be
huge and here he is winning Awards and
you still talk to him still yeah you
do yes well it's been a long time I
didn't know if you were still close yeah
I'm still close I know him I know his
his gal kirston and um they come to
Austin quite I think they actually might
buy a place here because you know he's
from Waco
so um yeah no I talk to them I talked to
I talk to a lot of the people Kyle lives
in Dripping Springs with his family Kyle
does I you think Kyle would ever do the
podcast I love Kyle oh god he's a hoot
he's so good as that
coach it was like I don't you can't be
more likable and cool than that dude oh
and you know what okay here's a story
for you hey guys I'm doing another live
podcast downtown LA at the Regent
Theater and my special guest for January
24th is Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad
Jessica Jones this is going to be a
soldout event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael rosenbom with special guest
Kristen r RIT I'm so excited so Linda
Loy our casting director who's brilliant
right uh does everything for for peterg
Peter wanted Dwight Yokum oh that would
have been tough a tough character it
would have been a very different
character different show and she was
like listen you have to see this guy you
have to see this guy and Peter will tell
you the story um and he's like no he was
that guy on that show with the newspap
ah he's too pretty he's too pretty he's
a pretty boy I don't want to see him
she's like listen we have to put up more
than one person you know what I mean
like you let's just just just other
people are coming in for sessions just
let them come
in and his hair was exactly how his hair
was on the show he took off his ball cap
he's like hey how y'all doing okay and
he just looked like he had had like too
many beers the night before and he was
just his hair was like this just
arai and Peter was like dude I'm sold
he's he's the guy he's the guy because
honestly I don't know that that show
would have been what it was if it had
been somebody other DWI y I love Dwight
Yokum and he's a great singer and he's a
great actor but Dwight Yokum is good for
a supporting character in a show not the
lead [__] coach that would have been
the worst decision ever there's I mean
what would have happened is the coach
would have died in the first season and
then they would had a new coach yes well
this is why also have casting directors